Sind Sie verliebt?
Ja, sehr.
- Ja, klar.
Manchmal schon, oder?
- Ja, ja.
Ich sehnte mich
nach einer reifen Beziehung
zwischen zwei
reifen, erwachsenen Menschen.
Und ... dann hatte ich
vier oder fünf Nachrichten.
Ich traf vier und fand: "Ui!"
"Nein, das darf nicht wahr sein."
"Es ist jetzt halt gelaufen."
Prost, Felix.
- Prost, Marta. Soll gelten.
Prost.
* Sanfte Pfeifmelodie *
Yvonne ist geschieden
und lebt seit acht Jahren
in einer Frauen-Wohngemeinschaft.
Also, das ist gut.
Sie hatte sich gut eingerichtet.
Auch ohne Partner war sie zufrieden.
Meistens.
Es gibt Bohnensalat, Tomatensalat,
diesen Käse und diesen Kräuterquark.
Ich war lange verheiratet,
25 Jahre lang.
Zwischen 22 und 47.
Mit ihrem Mann
hat sie drei Kinder grossgezogen
und ist heute zweifache Grossmutter.
Danach kam ich wieder
mit meiner Jugendliebe zusammen,
war nochmals 14 Jahre
mit einem Mann zusammen,
den ich von ganz jung an kannte.
Dann ging es mir gut alleine.
Ich suchte im VCS-Heft keinen Mann.
Ich schaute mir Ferienhäuser
und Wassersparduschen an.
Ich lese aus Prinzip die Inserate,
weil ich fast alle unmöglich finde.
Dann las ich vier Inserate.
Von Frauen, warm, erfahren,
lustig und älter und alles gut.
Ich dachte: "Eben nicht."
Dann kam eines von einem Mann,
bei dem ich laut loslachen musste.
"Mir stinkt's!"
"Jeden Morgen allein
am Frühstückstisch zu sitzen,
allein
durch die Botanik zu streifen,
immer alles allein tun zu müssen."
"Darum suche ich, 69-Jähriger,
85 kg ... Optimist dich,
jung - Klammer -
gebliebene, schlanke,
lebens- und unternehmungslustige
Radlerin, Wanderin, Geniesserin."
"Raum Zürich."
Ich musste sofort lachen
und hatte Lust,
auf dieses Inserat zu reagieren.
Einfach weil es
so aussergewöhnlich war.
Nicht verkrampft, originell.
Nicht alles dieses Attr.,
finan. unab., ohne Altl. ...
Alle
diese fürchterlichen Beschreibungen.
Sondern einfach: "Mir stinkt's,
ich möchte nicht mehr allein sein."
Sie schickte mir sofort
so eine Karte.
Sie hat sich bei mir also
sofort öffentlich bekannt gemacht.
Sie schrieb ... ähm ...
"Und dein -
ja, VCS-Leserinnen duzen sich -
Inserat hat mir gefallen."
"Schau halt, ob dich diese Worte
und das Bild ansprechen."
"Und sonst bitte alles zurück."
"Y, Yvonne."
Das Wichtigste.
Franz hat mehrere Beziehungen
und eine Ehe hinter sich.
Seine zwei Buben
sind längst erwachsen
und Franz ist seit ein paar Jahren
leidenschaftlicher Grossvater.
Es war Sommer 2017
und Franz ging es eigentlich
ganz gut ohne Partnerin.
Er wohnte zwar alleine,
fühlte sich aber nicht einsam.
So.
So, ich wünsche mir jetzt
guten Appetit.
* Rockballade aus dem Radio *
Aber manchmal
fehlte ihm eben doch etwas.
Und darum reagierte er erfreut, als
Yvonne auf seine Annonce antwortete.
Dann schrieb er zurück,
legte auch ein Foto bei.
Er schrieb: "Das hat mir gefallen",
und gab mir seine Nummer
und seine Adresse.
Und sein Foto?
Ja, auf den ersten Blick war ich
ehrlich gesagt nicht begeistert.
Dennoch fand ich:
"Lass uns einen Kaffee trinken."
Mir gefiel, wie er schrieb,
ich wollte ihn kennenlernen.
Wir verabredeten uns
und trafen uns im Karl der Grosse.
An dem Abend war ich noch
zum Jassen verabredet.
Ich hatte einen Blumenstrauss
für meine Freundinnen dabei,
mit denen ich regelmässig jasse.
Sie dachte da schon,
die Blumen seien für sie.
Ich trat ein im Karl der Grosse
und erkannte ihn sofort.
Er sass dort, man erkannte ihn.
In echt gefiel er mir
viel besser als auf dem Foto.
Er hatte einen wunderschönen
Blumenstrauss dabei,
der aber für seine Jass-Frauen war.
Dann lernte ich einen
ganz liebenswürdigen Menschen kennen
und wir hatten
eine ganz offene, entspannte Stunde.
Wir trennten uns beide
mit einem guten Gefühl
und hatten Lust, das fortzusetzen.
Sie hat mich
ab dem ersten Moment fasziniert.
Es ist nicht falling in love -
platsch, so rein.
Sondern es ist:
einen Stuhl hinstellen und schauen,
ob sich die Liebe
und das Glück draufsetzen.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
In Zermatt hat Pierre
sein spätes Glück gefunden.
Da war er 67 Jahre alt.
Sport
war dem Geschäftsmann immer wichtig.
Verheiratet war er nie,
hatte aber immer lange Beziehungen.
Meist zu viel jüngeren Frauen.
Dieses Jahr wird er 79.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
Gudrun ist bald 75 Jahre alt.
Über 30 Jahre war sie
glücklich verheiratet, ohne Kinder.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
Ah, schön.
Sie war Friseuse
mit eigenem Geschäft in Deutschland.
Vor 35 Jahren kam sie mit ihrem Mann
das erste Mal nach Zermatt
und es gefiel ihnen sehr hier.
Aber plötzlich war sie
mit Anfang 60 wieder alleine.
2002 ist er leider verstorben.
Nach fünf Jahren starb auch
meine Mutter, die alt war,
und meine Schwester,
die sehr krank war.
Ich hatte gerade mein Geschäft
aufgegeben - ich war also frei.
Irgendwie war ich frei.
Mit dem Tod kam ich besser klar.
Und da war ich wieder offen.
Mir hat jemand gefehlt.
Ich sagte immer: "Wenn ich
noch mal den Richtigen treffe,
sage ich nicht Nein.
Ich möchte nicht immer allein sein."
Nach fünf Jahren ...
Ich kam mit einem Freund,
der in Zürich lebt,
mit dem ich mich immer hier traf -
er war aber wie ein Sohn -
ebenfalls hierher.
Dann sass Pierre hier.
Er merkte, dass ich nicht
zu diesem Mann gehöre.
Nein, das merkte ich nicht.
- Ja ...
Ich dachte zunächst, das sei ihr
Bodyguard, er war so aufgeblasen.
Ja, ja, er passte halt auf mich auf.
Es entstand eine Art Magnetfeld.
Ja.
- Um sie herum?
Das hat mich quasi angezogen.
Und dann
landeten wir in dieser Ecke.
Und der Bodyguard ... Den haben wir
dann zur Seite geschoben.
Man kann so ein Magnetfeld
nicht beschreiben.
Man geht an jemandem vorbei
und es ist,
als würde man
einen Stromschlag kriegen.
Man kann es nicht beschreiben,
es ist einfach so.
Ich dachte: "Ich hab nichts zu
verlieren, ich bin jetzt ja frei."
Und dann hat's geschnackelt.
Und dann
waren die zwei Wochen wunderschön.
Lach nicht so lüstern!
- Ja.
Du erzählst das so gut.
- Ja, es ist aber so.
Ich war wieder so verliebt, wie ...
Das gibt's gar nicht.
Die Gefühle bleiben,
egal wie alt man ist.
Die Haut, die Hülle altert,
aber die Gefühle bleiben.
Ja.
Wir machen das so, wie man das
im Alter macht - für andere.
Da ist es ja nur so ...
* Kussgeräusch *
Das war jetzt aber harmlos.
Einen richtigen
wollen wir auch nicht machen.
Das ist ja eklig.
Denken die Jungen.
Aber es gehört dazu
und es ist sehr schön.
Es ... es ist eigentlich schöner,
als wenn man jung ist.
Das Körperliche? Die Sexualität?
- Ja, finde ich schon.
Warum?
Weil man nicht so viel erwartet,
man hat keinen Erfolgsdruck.
Man lässt es einfach so ...
Man kriegt nicht mehr
ungewollt ein Kind.
Man kann es mehr geniessen.
Eindeutig.
- Und es ist auch sehr lustig.
Man nimmt es mit mehr Humor -
ich jedenfalls.
Du auch.
- Warum ist es lustig?
Wenn's mal nicht so richtig klappt,
lacht man drüber.
Oder ich sag:
"Komm, wir bringen's hinter uns!"
Und wir brauchen auch nur
so ein kleines Bett.
Wir schlafen auf 90 cm.
Das ist sonst das Privileg
der jungen Frischverliebten.
Ja, aber bei uns
ist es wie bei den alten Hunden:
Wir brauchen die Wärme.
So richtig ...
Aber da tut sich nix. Nicht, dass du
denkst, da wäre jedes Mal ...
Einfach nur ...
es ist einfach schön.
Ich wünschte,
viel mehr Menschen hätten das.
Es macht glücklich.
Nicht immer glücklich.
Glücklich sein ist auch immer
nur ein Moment. Aber zufrieden.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Vielen Dank.
Der hier ist übrigens der beste.
Gutteli.
- I wish you what.
Sie leben seit zwölf Jahren
als Paar zusammen
und verbringen jeweils
mehrere Monate im Jahr
in ihrem Sehnsuchtsort Zermatt.
* Sanfte Klänge *
* Kussgeräusche *
Ach, du küsst ja so schön.
* Sanfte, drollige Klänge *
Felix Lötscher hat als Architekt
viele Häuser und Kirchen gebaut.
Seine Frau und er
haben vier Kinder grossgezogen.
Nach 20 Ehejahren hat sie sich wieder
in ihren Jugendfreund verliebt -
und plötzlich stand er alleine da.
Als meine Frau und ich uns trennten,
versprachen wir den Kindern,
dass wir zusammenbleiben,
bis alle ausgewachsen sind.
Das ging dann zehn Jahre.
Ich dachte, das sei dann
gar kein Problem für mich,
denn ich hatte zehn Jahre geübt,
allein zu sein.
Und dann ist das ...
Ich hätte das nie geglaubt.
Dann fuhr mir das so ein:
"Jetzt bist du einfach allein."
"Niemand kommt mehr,
du kannst niemanden mehr erwarten."
Das ist Wahnsinn.
Ich dachte dann ...
Ich war derart engagiert,
hatte kaum Beziehungen mit anderen
Personen oder anderen Frauen.
Da wusste ich nicht: "Wie möchte ich
das überhaupt ändern?"
Ich reagierte dann
eine Weile lang auf Inserate.
Es wurde aber nie etwas daraus.
Die Suche nach einer Partnerschaft
stand stark im Vordergrund.
Und in dem Moment
kam beim Skifahren in Flims
die Begegnung
mit diesem grauen Kopf von hinten.
Mit dem weissen Kopf.
Und dann zündete es sogleich.
- Weiss klingt besser als grau.
* Er lacht. *
Ich hielt mal an -
er fuhr immer hinter mir.
Ich hielt also an
und dann hielt er auch an.
Er begann, mit mir zu plaudern.
Ja, ja, es ...
Weisst du noch, was du sagtest?
Es war ja Winter.
Und du dachtest immer:
"Der soll mal die Mütze ausziehen."
"Wie alt ist er?"
Du warst glücklich, als du sahst,
dass ich auch graue Haare habe.
Wir fuhren kaum Ski.
Ja, wir gingen immer
von einem Restaurant zum anderen.
Dann sagte ich: "Lass uns
irgendwo gut zu Abend essen."
Und sie sagte:
"Ich gehe jetzt heim schlafen."
"Auf Wiedersehen, Herr Lötscher."
Streng.
- Ich dachte: "Herrschaft noch mal!"
Und zu Hause ...
Ich ging zuerst in die Telefonkabine
und schrieb mir
sofort die Adresse raus.
Ich schrieb ihr einen Brief, ob wir
uns irgendwo wieder treffen könnten.
Doch es kam einfach keine Antwort.
Dann sagte ich mir:
"Ich rufe sie jetzt einfach an."
Dann sagte sie: "Hier ist Trindler."
Und ich: "Hier ist Lötscher."
"Grüezi, Herr Lötscher."
Sie reagierte überhaupt nicht.
"Ich schrieb Ihnen einen Brief."
Ich hatte den Briefkasten
noch nicht geleert.
Der war nicht bei der Wohnung.
Der war weit weg,
bei der Hauptstrasse.
Dann sagte sie,
sie würde ihn leeren gehen.
Nach ca. 20 Min.
rief sie mich zurück.
Ich fragte sie,
ob sie Probleme habe,
weil sie so lange gewartet hatte.
Sie sagte, sie habe ihn
etwa dreimal lesen müssen,
sie freue sich derart.
Ich fuhr nochmals hoch und
wir waren zwei, drei Tage zusammen.
Wir haben ...
Wir sind nicht viel Ski gefahren.
Aber ...
Ja, es war schön,
dass ich jemanden gefunden hatte,
der in meinem Alter war - sie ist
zwar wesentlich älter als ich.
Aber auch jemanden, der frei ist.
Ja.
Ich suchte nicht, doch dann
liefst du mir über den Weg.
* Er lacht. *
Aber spät.
Das ist doch gut, oder?
- Ja, ja.
Ja, ja.
Ich habe
einen jungen Kerl neben mir.
Marta, darf ich so kommen
oder muss ich ein Hemd anziehen?
Du musst selbst wissen,
ob du schön sein willst oder nicht.
Doch.
Gehen wir essen?
- Wie?
Der Mann geht voraus.
Gut. - Nein, eigentlich
müsstest du mir den Vortritt lassen.
Ihre späte Liebe
begann vor 20 Jahren.
Damals war sie 71 und er 64.
Sie sind oft und weit
zusammen gereist,
lebten aber in getrennten Wohnungen.
Vor elf Jahren
sind sie zusammengezogen,
in eine Seniorenresidenz.
(Frau) Grüezi miteinander.
- Grüezi wohl.
Vor vier Jahren haben sie geheiratet.
Für Marta war es das erste Mal.
Die vier Kinder und sechs Enkel
von Felix sind nun auch ihre Familie.
Marta war Chefsekretärin
und in der Freizeit Ballonpilotin.
Für eine Beziehung
hatte sie keine Zeit.
Aber eben, da begegnete ihr Felix
und es war um sie geschehen.
Sollen wir
den Ballon schon auslegen?
Nein, wir kippen ihn zunächst,
dann sehen wir,
wie weit weg man dort ...
* Mechanisches Rattern *
Marta war früher eine Pionierin
der Schweizer Ballonfahrt.
Nun zeigen sich zunehmend
Symptome einer Demenz.
Du musst da halten.
Von ihren Ballonfahrten
weiss sie noch, wer alles mitkam,
und die Probleme, die ...
Wenn wir unterwegs waren, sagte sie:
"Hier hatten wir Windprobleme ..."
Überall hat sie Erfahrungen,
an die sie sich noch erinnert.
Kurzzeitgedächtnis  -
am Anfang hatte ich grosse Mühe,
damit umzugehen.
Denn wenn ich was sagte, stellte sie
2 Min. später dieselbe Frage.
Am Anfang reagierte ich jeweils
fast ein wenig verärgert:
"Ich sagte ja gerade,
es sei so und so."
Du übertreibst es.
- Nein, das ist ...
Doch.
- Nein, Schatz. Äh ...
Du fängst an, abzubauen,
das ist ganz klar.
Das ist eine normale Erscheinung
in dem Alter.
Für mich
ist es eine Herausforderung,
das in die Hände nehmen,
unterstützen zu dürfen.
So gut und so lange ich das kann.
Wir nehmen jeden Tag als Geschenk,
ohne grosse Pläne ...
Vorab nehmen.
- ... was morgen ist.
Heute ist heute. Wir haben es
jetzt schön und wir geniessen es.
Was morgen sein wird,
wissen wir nicht.
Lass das Glas nicht fallen!
- Nein.
* Gemächliche Pfeifmelodie *
Das ist ein Alterseinschenken:
zweihändig.
* Fröhliche Pfeifmelodie *
Weil man zittert.
Prost, Felix.
- Prost, Marta. Soll gelten.
Prost.
* Gemächliche Klänge *
Das war in der Wüste von ...
Ein schönes Foto.
Ja, da warst du noch jung.
Im Betagtenzentrum Rosenberg
in Luzern
leben rund 120 Pensionärinnen
und Pensionäre.
Die Leiterin Cati Hürlimann
weiss um deren Bedürfnisse -
auch in Liebesdingen.
Hallo zusammen.
Das ist ein Lebensraum,
und zwar einer,
der alles beinhaltet,
was zum menschlichen Leben gehört,
von der Geburt bis zum Tod.
Liebe, Zärtlichkeit,
Sexualität, Nähe ...
Beziehungen zu leben,
ist auch ein grosses Thema.
Im Durchschnitt
sind die Menschen hier 87 Jahre alt.
Sie brauchen eine sensible Führung
und häufig ein offenes Ohr.
Auch für Liebesgeschichten,
für die es selbst als Bewohnerin
oder Bewohner eines Seniorenzentrums
nie zu spät ist.
Es kam schon vor, dass sich Menschen
im Rosenberg kennenlernten
und ein Paar wurden.
Das ist manchmal nicht ganz einfach,
weil natürlich
auch die Angehörigen da sind,
die es unter Umständen
nicht so toll finden,
dass ihr Vater oder ihre Mutter
jemand Neues kennenlernt.
Da stellt sich die Frage:
Gehört sich das noch?
Oder auch die Frage:
Es waren frühere
Partner oder Partnerinnen da,
die vielleicht verstorben sind -
wie geht man damit um?
Kann man es aushalten,
dass die Mutter
nun wie ein verliebter Teenager
durch die Gegend läuft?
Manchmal lebt ein Ehepartner
noch in der alten Wohnung
und der oder die andere
bereits im Betagtenzentrum
und teilt sich das Zweierzimmer
mit einer fremden Person.
Wenn zwei Personen
gemeinsam in einem Zimmer leben,
die jetzt kein Paar sind,
sondern die das Leben
so zusammengebracht hat ...
Wenn man einem anderen Menschen
nun körperlich begegnen möchte,
das ist sehr schwierig.
Dann schaut man eher,
dass das ausserhalb des Rosenbergs
stattfinden kann,
damit auch der Schutz
der Intimsphäre gewährleistet ist.
Nicht nur die Mitbewohnerinnen
und Mitbewohner beobachten,
was in Liebesdingen
so läuft im Haus,
auch das Personal
muss sich damit auseinandersetzen.
Sie müssen im Team Lösungen finden,
wenn Menschen sich einsam fühlen,
Wünsche
nach sexueller Stimulation äussern,
berührt werden wollen
oder eben nicht.
Die Reaktion
auf Bewohnerinnen oder Bewohner,
die ihre Sexualität leben wollen,
die kann ganz unterschiedlich sein.
Es gibt Menschen,
die das total normal finden
und Verständnis dafür haben.
Es gibt aber natürlich auch Bilder,
wo man sagt:
"Das ist doch eklig!"
"Jetzt müssen sich so Alte
auch noch so verhalten."
Bis hin zu: "Braucht es das noch?"
Oder eben auch Werthaltungen,
die aus einer Tradition stammen,
in der man sagt: "Sie waren einmal
verheiratet, das reicht jetzt."
Da gibt es wirklich alles.
Vor einigen Jahren hatten wir
einen Bewohner, der klar sagte ...
... er hätte gerne
eine Prostituierte.
Wir schauten uns das an
und fanden dann:
In diesem Zimmer,
in diesem Setting, in dem er ist,
ist das nicht möglich,
denn das wäre zu stigmatisierend.
Aber er war in der Lage,
den Rosenberg zu verlassen,
wenn auch in einem Rollstuhl.
Dann klärten wir mal ab,
welche Angebote es
in der näheren Umgebung gibt.
Wir zeigten ihm das dann auf
und verschafften ihm den Zugang.
Dann musste er das
natürlich dann selbst organisieren.
Aber wir fuhren ihn hin
und holten ihn dann auch wieder ab.
Mit dieser Offenheit
stösst sie bei Angehörigen
oder auch bei Mitarbeitenden
gelegentlich auf Unverständnis.
Ja, ich glaube, man muss dann
einfach die Gespräche führen
und sagen:
"Worum geht es nun jetzt?"
"Geht es
um meine persönliche Werthaltung
in Bezug
auf diese Art von Dienstleistung?"
"Oder geht es um den Menschen?"
* Sanfte Klänge *
Yvonne und Franz geniessen
seit neun Monaten ihre späte Liebe.
Franz hat Yvonne erzählt,
dass er an der nicht heilbaren
Lungenkrankheit COPD leidet.
Trotzdem -
oder vielleicht gerade deshalb -
schmieden sie oft Pläne.
Ich kann mir viele Dinge vorstellen.
Von der Bretagne bis hin
zu einem Camper und allem Möglichen.
Vielleicht machen wir
gewisse Dinge auch nicht.
Andererseits
müssen wir gewisse Dinge machen,
weil wir nicht genau wissen,
wie viel Zeit für alles bleibt.
Wie es weitergeht, weiss man nie.
- Ja.
Wir gehen ins Wasser. Adieu.
Wir gehen ins Wasser. Ich kann
die Schuhe anlassen, du nicht.
Ich trage Wasserschuhe.
Fall nicht hin!
- Nein.
Sonst hast du Pech gehabt.
Franz ist so schwer in Ordnung
und hat so ein gutes Herz.
Er ist eine entspannte Person,
die mir sehr guttut.
Er bringt mich zum Lachen und ...
Aber vielleicht
hängt es auch damit zusammen,
dass er wie ein Wahnsinniger kocht
und die Liebe durch den Magen ging.
Wer weiss?
Ich finde,
sie ist eine ganz herrliche Frau.
Ich hätte nie gedacht,
dass es das noch gibt.
Jemand, der so auf mich stimmt, auf
mich eingeht, auf meine Bedürfnisse.
Jemand,
der auch mit mir umgehen kann.
Hüa!
- Ich muss hier wegkommen.
Hüa! Geht es auch etwas schneller?
Ja, jetzt kannst du wieder
grosse Töne spucken.
Du Grossmaul, du.
So.
Und tschüss.
* Fröhliche Pfeifmelodie *
Huch! Noch nicht!
Nein, Franz, hör auf!
* Sanfte, fröhliche Klänge *
* Sie kreischt. *
Geh endlich!
Grauenhaft!
Ich habe jetzt noch eine Frage:
Sie zeigen sich in der Badehose.
Das ist auch immer eine Challenge,
egal wie alt man ist.
Ja, ja.
Aber sich gegenseitig zu zeigen,
wenn man schon einzelne Falten hat
oder nicht mehr alles so straff ist -
wie ist das?
Was? Wo?
Wie muss man sich das vorstellen?
- Du siehst hier ihre Eitelkeit.
Ich finde,
das ist eine Herausforderung.
Ich sagte zu ihm, ich fände es
auch noch mutig, dass er schreibt,
er suche eine schlanke Partnerin,
doch selbst so aussieht.
Er sagte dann:
"Ja, wünschen kann man alles."
Ich finde,
dort zeigt sich ultimativ,
ob man - auch wenn es mal
schöner war - zu sich selbst steht,
mit allem, was verwelkt ist,
und ob man sich ...
Ich muss ehrlich sagen,
ich hatte Mühe mit Franz' Bauch.
Ja.
- Das verstehe ich auch.
Und Franz sagt: "Mich gibt es
nur so. Und es ist nicht wichtig."
Aber es ist eine Herausforderung
ans Ego und an die Eitelkeit.
Ja, ein wenig wichtig ist es
schon auch, das leuchtet mir ein.
Aber ich kann den Bauch
nicht einfach wegzaubern.
Es ging auch lange,
bis ich ihn mir angefressen hatte.
Zum einen sage ich: "Zieh bitte
ein Hemd an, kein T-Shirt,
das gefällt mir besser."
Zum anderen ...
Nein, ehrlich, danach ...
Bei Zärtlichkeiten hat man einfach
einen lebendigen,
warmen, liebevollen Menschen.
Dann ist es zumindest mir
auch Wurst, ob es verwelkt ist.
Wir haben auch schon
Menschen durch den Tod verloren.
Kurz bevor ich Franz kennenlernte,
starben meine Schwester
und meine allerälteste,
liebste Freundin.
Beide starben - mit 63.
Dann denke ich: "Mein Gott,
es mag ja schlabbern und alles,
aber ich bin 63, ich lebe,
mein Liebhaber lebt - so what?"
Es ist wirklich
eine Frage der Prioritäten.
Das ist alles nicht mehr wichtig,
wir sind am Leben.
Das mit der Wichtigkeit
finde ich auch.
Wirklich.
* Kreischen *
Küss die Hühneraugen.
Da kommt schon die Seepolizei.
Wegen unsittlichen Betragens?
- Genau.
* Fröhliche Pfeifmelodie *
Die 78-jährige Yvonne
lebte rund 20 Jahre alleine.
Ihren ersten Kuss
bekam sie von Peter.
Damals war sie 17.
Die beiden haben sich seither, also
seit 59 Jahren, nicht mehr gesehen.
Dabei wohnte Peter
noch immer ganz in der Nähe.
Aber das wusste sie nicht.
Peter ist inzwischen 80.
Auch er hatte keine Ahnung,
dass sein ehemaliger Schatz
seit vielen Jahren um die Ecke lebt.
Erstaunlicherweise
sind sie sich nie begegnet.
Vor zwei Jahren fing er allerdings
an, von Yvonne zu träumen.
Und er hat sich
an die Küsse von damals erinnert.
Ich war 19. Oder 18.
- Ich war 17.
Du 17.
Ja.
Natürlich waren wir beide
noch Anfänger, ganz schüchtern.
Das blieb dann
natürlich beim Küsschen.
Ja, ja.
Wir trafen uns dann mehr,
beim Tanzen, nicht wahr?
Aber plötzlich
hörte ich nichts mehr von ihm.
Das war so: Ich wollte mit 19 die RS
machen, um mit 20 auszuwandern.
Dann hatte ich einen Lungenfleck
und ich konnte nicht gehen.
Und wie es so kommt:
Man trifft jemand anderes.
Dann knisterte es halt dort.
Ich heiratete, bekam zwei Kinder.
Und ...
Ich war 51 Jahre lang verheiratet.
2014 ist meine Frau
an Krebs gestorben.
Nach einer langen Leidenszeit.
Danach war ich wirklich frei,
konnte machen, was ich wollte.
Dann sagte ich
meinen Freunden prinzipiell:
"Ich möchte keine Frau mehr,
ich lebe jetzt allein."
Ich habe später auch geheiratet,
1963. Ich bekam auch zwei Kinder.
Es ging ganz normal weiter.
Mit 58 war ich wieder allein.
Ich wollte keinen Mann mehr. Nein.
Ich hab mich so eingerichtet,
dass es mir gut geht.
Danach kam dieser Brief - von Peter.
Ich sah beim Absender
"Peter Wipflin".
Ich dachte:
"Was möchte Peter jetzt von mir?"
"Hallo Yvonne. Erschrecke nicht,
es lässt mich nicht mehr los."
"Weil ich keine Telefonnummer
von dir finde, schreibe ich dir."
"Seit einiger Zeit kommst du mir
immer wieder im Traum vor."
"Verstehe mich recht,
ich suche keine Freundin."
Als wir uns trafen,
merkte ich schon: Oh ...
Wir begrüssten uns gleich,
als ob es nie einen Stillstand
zwischen uns gegeben hätte.
Dann merkte ich,
dass er ganz nervös war.
Danach gingen wir ins Elite essen.
- Ich bin jetzt noch nervös.
Nach all den Jahren
haben sich die Frischverliebten
unglaublich viel zu erzählen.
Und schon beim ersten Treffen
offenbarte Peter Yvonne,
dass er keine Erektion mehr
haben kann.
Plötzlich sagtest du mir
das von der Prostata.
Ich sagte zu ihm: "Weisst du, wie
viele Frauen so einen Mann wollen?"
Im Alter wollen viele ja
keinen Geschlechtsverkehr mehr.
Ich sagte,
ich sei auch eine von denen.
Ich wäre ...
Mir würde das nichts ausmachen.
Mhm.
- Mhm.
Es gibt genügend Möglichkeiten,
man kann es auch sonst schön haben.
Sie unternehmen viel
und besuchen sich fast täglich
gegenseitig in ihren Wohnungen.
Und sie sind überrascht,
wie viele Interessen sie teilen.
Trotz Verliebtheit
wollen sie nicht zusammenziehen,
weil sie die Fallstricke kennen.
Sie hat ein anderes System -
abtrocknen usw. - als ich.
Ich habe zu Hause ein
Abtrocknungstuch, das ist für alles.
Sie hat eines fürs Geschirr
und eines für die Pfannen.
Das kenne ich nicht.
Wenn ich dann
das falsche Tuch nehmen würde:
"Du musst das andere nehmen."
Dann wäre ich schon sauer geworden.
Das sagte ich nie.
Auch wenn ich zu dir komme.
Ich sehe, du hast eines,
und sage auch nichts.
Du bist dort zu Hause und ich hier.
Man muss es einfach so sein lassen,
wie es ist.
Ich möchte meine Freiheit behalten.
Ich will das nicht mehr.
Ich wünsche mir auch, dass wir
unsere Freiheit behalten können.
Er hat seine Hobbys. Jeder darf
machen, was er davor gemacht hat.
D.h., sie pflegen auch
ihren Freundeskreis wie bisher.
* Stimmengewirr, Lachen *
Eins, zwei, drei!
Ich kam wieder pünktlich.
* Alle prosten sich zu. *
Prost, Peter.
Prost.
* Zufriedenes Ausatmen *
Wir haben schon gemerkt, dass sich
etwas geändert hat. Definitiv.
Er hüpfte und sprang umher.
* Peter lacht. *
Er konnte zwar keinen Service
mehr abnehmen, nichts mehr ...
(Mann)
Nein, aber es war schon gegenseitig,
dass es so funktioniert hat.
Und er ist wirklich ...
Nochmals Frühling.
Ja, ich bin
zehn Jahre jünger geworden.
Auch im Spiel
legte er auf einmal zu, Wahnsinn.
Ernsthaft?
Ja, er ist viel besser geworden.
* Sanfte Panflötenklänge *
Es ist wirklich schön,
das auch mal miterleben zu können.
Wir sagen immer, wenn wir später
mal alleinstehend sein sollten
und uns das auch passieren würde,
dann wäre es sicher ...
(Frau)
Dann freuen wir uns aufs Alter.
... würden wir uns
aufs Alter freuen.
Sie geniessen es,
gehen voll rein. Egal welches Alter.
* Sanfte Chilloutklänge *
Man kann fast nicht glauben,
dass einem das noch passiert.
Das ist nicht selbstverständlich.
Jetzt hätte ich gerne ein Küsschen.
Immer noch.
* Sanfte Chilloutklänge *
Eine späte Liebe zu finden,
braucht manchmal Mut und Ausdauer.
Hans ist 80
und war zweimal verheiratet.
Der Witwer lebt allein -
und er fühlt sich einsam.
Und jetzt bin ich halt
ernsthaft auf der Suche.
Es ist nicht einfach.
Ich habe alle Partnervermittlungen
angeschrieben, war auch dabei.
Aber null Resultate.
Wenn mich jemand fragt: "80?" -
abgeschrieben.
Das ist einfach ein Alter
zwischen Leben und Scheintod.
Ich kann es nicht anders sagen.
Das schockiert einen sehr.
Jetzt habe ich
im Internet wieder geschrieben:
"Gibt es in dieser Gruppe
keine Frau ab 60,
die noch eine Beziehung
eingehen möchte?"
Als Erstes kam:
"Ja, wie alt sind Sie denn?"
Mogeln: 70.
Ich hörte nichts mehr. Nichts mehr.
Jetzt gibt es natürlich
Leute oder Frauen, die sagen:
"Mit 70 oder 80 braucht der das hier
nur noch, um Wasser zu lösen,
aber sonst nicht mehr."
Ich kann ja nicht schreiben,
was ich sonst noch mache.
Aber ...
Man ist einfach abgeschrieben.
Das tut so weh.
Ist Ihnen auch wichtig,
wie sie aussieht?
Wichtig ... Aussehen ...
In der Liebe gibt es kein Alter,
keine Distanz und kein Aussehen.
Mir ist lieber,
sie hat einen guten Charakter.
Und dass sie lieb und zärtlich ist.
Die Zärtlichkeit
gibt ja das Aussehen.
Ich möchte einfach
mit jemandem spazieren gehen,
über alles diskutieren können,
was einen plagt.
Das ist das, was mir gefallen würde.
Irgendwo gut essen gehen,
tanzen gehen -
das kann ich nicht auslassen.
Das ist halt einfach
ein Teil meines Lebens.
Ich tanze noch Rock'n'Roll
wie ein 40-Jähriger.
Das sagt man mir,
das sage ich nicht von mir aus.
Ich bin danach schon fix und fertig,
das ist klar.
Aber dieser Takt, dieser Rhythmus,
das fasziniert mich einfach derart.
* Sanfte Schlagermusik *
Tanznachmittage für Senioren
wie hier in Münchenstein
sind als Partnerbörse beliebt.
Viele kommen
allerdings schon als Paar.
Das wiederum ist schwierig für
Singles in der zweiten Lebenshälfte.
* Sanfte Schlagermusik *
* Gefühlvolle Schlagermusik *
Besser geht's nicht mehr.
Sind Sie schon in Begleitung?
* Sanfte Volksmusik *
Danke schön.
- Ja.
* Unverständliche Gespräche *
Das geht durch ganz Europa hindurch.
Danke schön.
Ist gut?
* Fetzige Rock'n'Roll-Musik *
Ich komme mir vor
wie in alten Zeiten.
* Fetzige Rock'n'Roll-Musik *
Machen wir mal was ab? Wenn du
Zeit hast, wenn ich Zeit habe.
Ja, ich nehme mir Zeit.
Vielleicht
ergibt sich daraus ja etwas.
Wer weiss?
... und Schönheitsding ...
Yvonne und Franz sind seit einem Jahr
ein glückliches Paar.
Jetzt wollen sie tanzen lernen.
Wir machen jetzt immer
drei Schritte am Platz.
Eins, zwei, drei - dann der andere:
eins, zwei, drei.
Ich würde sagen,
das ist kein Problem.
Nein.
- Auf drei zählen können wir noch.
Warten, warten, warten, warten!
* Rhythmische Musik:
"Mambo Italiano" von Sophia Loren *
# Hey, mambo, mambo Italiano.
# Go, go, go you mixed up Sicialiano.
# All you Calabrese
do the mambo like a crazy.
* Fetzige Musik:
"Istanbul (Not Constantinople)" *
# Been a long time gone,
Constantinople.
# Now it's Turkish delight
on a moonlit night.
# Every gal in Constantinople lives
in Istanbul, not Constantinople.
# So, if you've a date
in Constantinople
# she'll be waiting in Istanbul.
Ich bringe ein anderes Lied,
denn das könnt ihr schon so gut.
* Lachen *
Ich muss es nur erwischen.
Ich muss rechts nach hinten.
Man darf immer auch mitzählen.
* Rockige Musik *
Hab ich nicht mehr nötig.
Dabei kannst du
nicht mal auf drei zählen.
Ta-ta-ta.
Das ist wunderbar.
Es war noch ... Wer macht jetzt ...
Sie macht einfach was anderes.
- Sie macht alles anders.
Das können wir jetzt ja.
Es ist ihr schon verleidet,
sie braucht was Neues.
Das ist so.
- Dann machen wir was Neues.
Ja, biete mir was!
* Sanfte Ballade:
"Perfect" von Ed Sheeran *
# ... with you between my arms.
Ich bin ein Naturtalent,
ich kann das schon.
Das ... ja.
Ich war auch schon in
einem Tanzkurs, etwa vor 50 Jahren.
Du sagtest mir, die Frauen hätten
sich um dich als Tänzer gerissen.
Mhm.
- Das sagst du jetzt wieder.
Stimmt es?
- Nein, es stimmt überhaupt nicht.
Ich gaffte
den schönen Mädchen immer nach.
Aber aus der Distanz.
- Aus der Distanz, ja.
# We are still kids,
but we're so in love
# fighting against all odds.
Ich glaube,
ich hätte mich nicht getraut,
so eine hübsche, lebensfrohe,
quicklebendige Person anzusprechen.
Damals.
Bravo. Weiter. Jawohl.
# Be my girl, I'll be your man.
# I see my future in your eyes.
Hast du Nani schon gesehen?
- Hoi zusammen.
Hallo.
- Hallo.
- Hoi. Zahlen?
Er hat alle Zahlen mitgebracht.
- Spatz.
Wolltest du die Zahlen mitnehmen?
Wie schnell ist der Zug gefahren?
Er ist ganz schnell gefahren.
- Etwa 100 km/h?
Hallo, lange nicht gesehen.
- Stimmt.
Das sagen wir immer,
wenn wir uns sehen:
Lange nicht gesehen.
Schau.
- Ja, jetzt sieht man es langsam.
Yvonne hatte,
bevor Franz in ihr Leben kam,
viel Zeit für ihre beiden Enkel.
Diese müssen ihre Grossmutter nun
mit dem neuen Partner teilen.
Ich merke, dass sie weniger Zeit
hat, aber im guten Sinne.
Sie hütet ja einmal fix.
Ich finde,
das ist nicht selbstverständlich.
Es ist ein grosses Geschenk.
Am Wochenende
hütet sie jetzt weniger,
aber das stört mich nicht,
weil ich das Gefühl habe,
sie ist dafür ...
sie macht dann tolle Sachen.
Eins, zwei -
und höher und grösser als Nana.
Davor überlegte man sich mehr,
was sie am Wochenende macht.
Oder man hatte eher
ein schlechtes Gewissen,
wenn sie mal
bei etwas nicht dabei sein konnte.
So weiss man:
Sie ist glücklich und auch versorgt.
Es ist ein ganz gutes Gefühl.
Das Fest zum 70. Geburtstag von Franz
ist für Yvonne eine Herausforderung.
Das gibt einen Spiessrutenlauf durch
die ganze Verwandtschaft hindurch.
Mal schauen, wie ich mich halte?
- Nervös?
Ja, schon ein wenig.
Ich möchte gut ankommen, das ist so.
Aber Hauptsache, ich passe Franz,
der Rest ist nicht wichtig.
Ueli.
Viva, prost.
Alles Gute, Franz.
- Gleichfalls.
* Alle prosten sich zu. *
Ich bin Rosmarie.
- Ich bin Yvonne.
Entschuldigung.
So sieht man mich auch.
Schau, das ist ... das ist Yvonne.
Das ist Renato.
- Ah, hallo.
Freut mich.
- Schon viel von dir gehört.
Je älter man ist,
umso mehr Freunde, Bekannte, Kinder
und Kindeskinder
bevölkern ein Leben.
Die gehören bei einer späten Liebe
dann halt auch dazu,
ob es einem passt oder nicht.
Die Exfrau von Franz
und Mutter seiner Söhne
hat nichts gegen Yvonne einzuwenden.
Das ist über 50 Jahre her.
Genauso wenig wie seine beiden Söhne.
... wenn er wie ein Baby ist.
Ich selbst habe mich sehr gefreut.
Ich habe ... ein wenig gemerkt, dass
ihm in seinem Leben etwas fehlte.
Als er mir das erzählte,
hatte ich das Gefühl,
dass man raushörte,
dass es jetzt die ...
dass es nun sehr gut passt.
Nicht nur vielleicht.
Das Buffet ist eröffnet!
* Jubel *
Man kann essen.
Hunger!
Man bekommt den Eindruck:
Franz spielt mit seiner Band
heute v.a. für Yvonne.
* Serbisches Volkslied: "Moja mala
nema mane" von Zvonko Bogdan *
# ... tako lepe dragane.
# Moja mala nema mane,
niko nema tako lepe dragane.
# Kad zagrli, kad poljubi,
u ljubavi sva se ona izgubi.
# Nema, nema, nema ona nikoga,
ona voli samo mene jednoga.
# Moja mala nema mane,
niko nema tako lepe dragane.
Das dort ist Yvonne. In der
Zwischenzeit kennen sie die meisten.
Yvonne ist für mich
einfach ein Glücksfall.
Sie war ein riesiger Glücksfall.
Vor einem Jahr oder sogar etwas mehr
schrieb ich ja ein Inserat.
Und ... ich fand: "Ich gebe mir
jetzt noch diese letzte Chance,
um irgendwo
nochmals Unterschlupf zu finden."
Und jetzt sind wir
schon bald ein Jahr zusammen.
Das ist wunderschön.
* Romantische Mandolinenklänge *
Das Rezept für eine späte Liebe:
ein bisschen Mut vielleicht.
Und - wie es Felix
und Marta so schön sagen:
Wir haben eine wahnsinnig grosse
Grosszügigkeit.
Jeder von uns
kann seinen Lebensrhythmus,
seine Interessen und so
leben und verfolgen.
Es ist kein ...
- ... Müssen.
... Einnehmen voneinander.
* Sanfte Klänge *
* Kussgeräusch *
Nicht so schnell.
Ich muss das wiederholen.
Ich kann nicht mehr.
* Fröhliche Pfeifmelodie *